hello everyone so this is going to be a
slightly different sort of video here
i'm not going to discuss any academic
matters rather i'm going to discuss
something very close to my heart
about using linux
now if you're a student from computer
science mathematics physics or even
electronics and electrical it is most
likely that you are going to end up
using linux at one point or another
there is a definite culture among the
senior students and even among the
professors there in those departments of
using linux and this culture kind of
brushes off on the young students and
the culture propagates in this way but
if you're student from other departments
for example mechanical civil aerospace
chemical and so on
this culture doesn't really exist so
the and the senior students and the
professors mostly use windows some
fashionable ones may be using mac but
hardly anyone uses linux at least that
is the general perception because there
are people who use linux even in those
departments they actually need to use
linux
so if you're a student and you are
suffering from this general mis
perception that people are not using
linux so uh should you be using linux
because it is very hard nowadays as a
modern student to be on the internet to
be a citizen of the internet and not
come across videos and content where
people discuss about the cool things
that you can possibly do with linux so
you may be in a sort of dilemma whether
you should go for this this need this
new thing this linux
now what is the right choice for you
because apparently there does not seem
to be much incentive if you're a student
from these departments this non-circle
circuited branches or maths and physics
so through this video i hope to dispel
some of the misconceptions and discuss
to you uh
in a very open and candid fashion some
of the advantages and the disadvantages
of using linux so to see i'm not trying
to be an evangelist here there are
people like linux evangelists who have
taken up on them like a holy mission of
converting all windows with users to
linux i'm not one of those guys i'll
just state to you the bare facts as they
are you decide for yourself whether you
want to try it or not
all right
my just my my only wish is that you take
an informed decision about it all right
so this video i'll divide into two parts
in the first part i'm going to try to
dispel some misconceptions i'll try to
address some of the possible doubts and
maybe highlight some of the advantages
the direct advantages of using linux and
then
uh
keeping in mind that i'm making this
video especially for students from
mechanical civil aerospace like the
non-surgical branches on maths and
physics
and perhaps even also either a student
from those branches and maybe on in two
minds about using linux i'll try to
state some of the things which uh
you
need to do officially
when you're using computers as you're
sitting in those departments and
try to discuss with you
whether by using linux you can do those
things whether
linux actually hinders you or helps you
in doing those things some of the
official things that you're supposed to
do so here we go so why should you even
consider using linux okay what is the
point of it
so uh instead of discussing in terms of
technicalities let me share with you my
own experience so if you are a computer
user maybe you have been using
windows
perhaps
the oldest version of windows that
you've used is windows 8 most likely
currently you are using windows 10 or
windows 11.
now since i am an old timer relatively
old timer i've been using windows
uh since windows 98 i think i saw
windows 95 but i did not ever touch it
uh
a windows 98 definitely but properly i
started using computers only using
windows xp so that was during my
undergraduate days and then during my
phd i used uh windows 7 and then as i
was finishing up my phd windows 8 game
so during my postdoc i had that on my
laptop windows 8 maybe it was windows
8.1 and when i started my job as an
assistant professor here at in the
mechanical engineering department of iit
kharagpur that was what i had okay and
then i bought a new laptop it had
windows 10
my experience is that at least starting
from windows 8 there is an inevitable
degradation in the windows and in the
user experience when using windows like
this kind of thing did not used to
happen when i was using windows xp and
windows 7. those were actually quite
good operating systems i never actually
used windows vest and those other
not so good versions i definitely use
windows xp and windows 7 and these kinds
of degradations and user experience over
the years that did not used to happen
but for windows 8 starting from windows
8 windows 10 it has definitely happened
like uh i have a new computer i have
this windows version and then within a
period of three to four years the
computer slows down now please trust me
when i say this i'm past that age where
i randomly uh install softwares from
here and there from shady websites or
games from shady websites that i will be
indiscriminately uh
installing malware into my system okay
so why is this kind of a degradation
happening so that was beyond me now in
the same computer this new laptop that i
had brought i think it was in 2017 and
which had incredibly slowed down out of
its own as i was using windows 10 on it
by 2020 when i installed uh linux on it
it suddenly came back to life like uh it
did not become blazingly fast and
nothing magical like that happened but
it kind of went back to its normal
performance as i had experienced it when
it was new so see there was nothing
wrong with the hardware so while why
when i was using windows that kind of
degradation happened that is beyond me
okay
uh
so this is this is my user experience so
my feeling is that these new versions of
windows they are doing something uh
well
either deliberately or
i don't know what they are doing but
this kind of degradation is happening
and this is probably going to happen
more and more uh and because they're
trying to do some kind of lockings uh
and telemetry uh
so there's a whole bunch of issues okay
now the next point that i want to dispel
is that
among many windows users there's a
notion that linux is only for
professional programmers or hackers
okay so this is
like patently untrue okay you should not
have any such notion and there's also
this notion that if you have to use
linux then you have to open up this this
uh this strange black terminal or
command line and the only things that
you can do in linux is using that
command line okay it is
absolutely not true maybe it was true
maybe 25 30 years ago but that is not
the case like current versions of linux
and there are many many of them you have
you're picking from them you can pick
whatever you want uh
so many different options like you're
spoiled for choice and many of them have
beautiful graphical user interfaces
probably much better than windows okay
so that is absolutely not a reason to
not pick linux okay
you can absolutely go by using linux
without ever opening up the command
prompt or the terminal okay that is
absolutely possible
uh the next thing is that uh see suppose
suppose you you use computers over four
or five years okay and you are you're
investing some time and effort over
using uh this computer with windows on
it what is the return of investment are
you learning anything new as the days go
by or you're doing the same exact same
things over and over again okay so you
are you're never becoming a power user
so to speak maybe you learn a few key
strokes
keyboard shortcuts but beyond that
what are you doing exactly so will it
perhaps not be a better idea for you to
start using something linux where
as you invest a little bit more effort
and time you actually learn some proper
technical savviness and
mind you if you use this thing
then in your cv you can actually write
down you can actually write down that
you know linux and that carries a lot of
weight especially if you're not from the
circuital branches okay that that shows
that you have some kind of incentive and
ability to do some kind of technical
adventure on your own all right the
other thing is that uh
well the obvious thing is that linux is
completely free like literally
officially free now this i'm saying as
an advantage many people think that's
because something is free maybe it is
like a cheap thing
okay so there is a difference between
free and cheap okay uh so
so please do appreciate that a lot of
effort
from brilliant engineers and computer
scientists from across the world have
gone into making linux like clinics is a
community driven uh kind of uh
operating system uh so uh
just because it is free doesn't mean
that it is of poor quality okay there is
uh like
a tremendous amount of technical
brilliance embedded into it
and of
believe it or not there is a lot of
electronic appliances all around you
which you use on a daily basis where
the back end of the software part is
actually based on linux
okay
in fact uh our smartphones the android
smartphones that uh
i mean the operating system is based off
linux
another definite advantage is that linux
is completely virus free uh
well
you take that with a grain of salt
because uh you should not think that it
is completely free from any sort of
security vulnerabilities it's not like
that but compared to windows it is like
orders of magnitude better okay like if
there is a security vulnerability in
linux it is actually newsworth it will
come in the news but it is such a daily
occurrence in windows that is not even
newsworthy
all right so these are some of the broad
strokes kind of advantages uh i wanted
to highlight uh to you so you see
there is
there are points in favor of considering
linux okay so these are the these are
some of the facts that i have told you
uh okay by the way another thing is that
uh in terms of customization okay so if
you're using a tool over time uh you
will have a general tendency especially
as a technical person to customize it to
your own requirements and needs
now
all of you actually do this even when
using windows you change the desktop
wallpaper you change the themes and the
fonts and whatever so why stop at those
cosmetic things when you can do so much
more and
linux gives you complete freedom to
make it as you want it to be okay so the
more you use it the more ideas you get
to tune it to your own uh
capabilities and to your own needs to
your own workflow styles you can
actually do it so there is an entire
world out there where you can use window
managers and things like that let's not
get into that but
trust me on this that
you can properly customize this
according to your will
okay so this was the first part of the
discussion the next part is where i want
to actually highlight to you the kind of
things where linux can uh actually help
you perhaps even hinder you uh in doing
your official needs or your official
businesses okay so
so as a student what do you need so
starting from the first year of your
engineering or science maybe you will
need to learn a little bit of
programming
as part of your programming and maybe
data structures classes so that's the
part of the common curriculum
all engineering institutes have that
and that you can very well do in windows
or linux
so it will be absolutely uh
be
lying on my part if i if i said that you
can do that only on linux certainly not
okay you can very well do programming in
windows and linux both
and for those kinds of basic uh
programming needs uh you certainly don't
need the massive uh
the massive advantages that linux
actually provides and this is true like
if you're a professional programmer then
certainly linux does offer you massive
advantages but in your first you
certainly don't need that
so
i just wanted to highlight that yes in
linux also you have these things
and if you are interested even from your
first year in programming then linux
certainly is the right way to go
next is uh
engineering drawing and computer
graphics so this is something which is
very much an integral part of mechanical
civil aerospace
naval architecture
perhaps even chemical i'm not sure but
it is very much an important part okay
so of course in first year every
department students has to learn these
things but as you go go along in the in
the higher classes in the higher years
the students from these departments have
to do further courses in these areas
also now in so this is a contentious
issue in the sense that the industry
standard in engineering drawing and
computer graphics nowadays uh arguably
is solidworks now solidworks is made by
a company which simply does not care
about linux so they do not actually make
installers
for solidworks to be installed on linux
now this seems to be directly an
argument for not ever using linux by
students from mechanical aerospace and
these are the departments civilian etc
but pause for a moment okay solidworks
is an expensive piece of software and
uh
not every institute can afford it
so there are institutes where people use
free and open source alternatives to
solid works they do exist for example
you have free cad lubricant
these kinds of softwares these are
definitely good they're not as good as
solidworks i won't lie to you okay like
nothing is as good as solidworks it is
really really good is there's a reason
why is the industry standard so if if as
a as a uh as as a stu as an engineering
student you are progressing through
years and you are developing some kind
of a professional interest like interest
to go into the profession of solid uh
solids modeling and engineering drawing
and computer graphics and all those
things
then
maybe don't i mean stay with windows
okay this is my personal advice to you
okay i told you that i'm not going to be
a linux evangelist so if that is what
you want to do stay with windows
that's the industry standard learn it
properly because
why would you waste your time learning
something which you're not going to
ultimately use professionally but at the
same time if your professor in an
institute is
teaching to you is teaching you using
freecad or librecad then don't go about
using solidworks uh through some other
means okay
you know what i'm talking about
use those uh alternatives and maybe
later on
as time comes
use solidworks i mean if it is actually
necessary
at the same time i've said that like
solidworks is the industry standard but
because it is a proprietary software it
is completely logged in okay like you
will not be able to see the source code
of it so if you are so much interested
in solids modeling and computer graphics
that you actually end up doing research
in this area then paradoxically it makes
sense for you to actually go with those
free and open source versions like
freecad librecad or maybe some other
cancer like there are numerous other cad
softwares free and open source where you
can actually tinker with the code
uh depending on the research direction
that you are pursuing you can actually
uh play around with the code change
things here and there things you cannot
do in solidworks okay so decide for
yourself what you want to do
next mathematical packages so again
uh
matlab and mathematica are of course
very professional software's they're
they're beautiful software's uh but at
the same time they are expensive okay
but the good thing is that unlike
solidworks both
matlab and mathematica
come with installers for linux like you
can properly install
matlab and mathematica in linux without
any intermediate software like wine or
bottles or anything like that okay you
can natively install them properly in
linux i have myself used matlab during
my postdoc
in linux in ubuntu
and it's definitely and mathematica is
also there okay and if you want to go
for some kind of open source alternative
to it
within the python environment you have
symbolic python numpy and whatnot and
then you also have octave
so
so alternatives do exist okay but see
me mentioning uh these alternatives
doesn't mean that they're only available
for linux okay they are available for
windows also so
you decide for yourself what you want to
do
next a very important part of your
training as a mechanical engineer civil
engineer aerospace engineer will be
learning finite element packages so
the the leaders in this are definitely
uh
well it's a
kind of a personal opinion but i think
many people will agree with me that the
leaders are ansys uh abacus and to a
large extent uh comsol also console
multiphysics okay so here in our
department many of the phd students use
these softwares on a daily basis
uh and i'm sure in other institutions
also this will be the same kind of
situation so
and the good news is that
ansys abacus console they are all
natively installable in linux okay and i
want to highlight something here that
i am also not a free and open source
evangelist okay there are some fanatics
who will swear by free and open source
they will not touch anything proprietary
i'm not like that my philosophy is that
use the best tool for the job
okay use the best tool for the job
always so if your job requires you to
use matlab or to use abacus or to use
comsol use that okay don't get hung up
on this free and open source uh
of like philosophy okay philosophy will
come later okay first do your job
properly which is not to say that i i
don't support free and open source i
definitely support i wherever possible
if nobody is dictating terms to me i
will first try to use a free and open
source uh thing so all my youtube videos
here are made using free and open source
softwares uh
all the video editing and the and the
thumbnails and everything and uh
for other things also i try as far as
possible use free and open source but
i'm not getting hung up on those things
so i think it's it's not a good
philosophy to get hung up on those
things
okay
uh uh staying so coming back to finite
element packages you definitely have
ansys uh because console that can be
absolutely be installable in linux so
there is so linux will not hinder you
from learning these packages okay
on the contrary if you are actually
interested in the long term on high
performance computing which is like the
serious level research kind of thing in
these areas
then learning linux will actually be a
no a great advantage to you like you'll
get a definite head start if you learn
start learning linux from your
undergraduate days only by the time you
become a phd student uh you will have a
tremendous head start over many of the
other
research scholars over the other phds
candidates okay so in high performance
computing linux is the way to go um
the way that you can handle servers uh
and uh high-end clusters and high-end
machines computational machines are
mostly using linux okay so there's a
definite
argument to be made
for the for the use of linux in these
areas okay
next uh again staying on this topic of
fine element packages
there is one very professional level a
fine element package where the
mathematical background is very very
robust
because
uh proper mathematicians have developed
it have worked with computer science
scientists to develop this and it's
called phoenix it's a relatively newer
package
but
phoenix
believe it or not is actually more
easily installable in linux it is
possible to install it in windows but
it's a massive pane i mean you can use
it
i mean you can you can install it using
something called docker but then docker
doesn't get installed on windows home
edition uh so there's a whole litany of
issues it's it's a breeze to install it
in linux so
if you are more mathematically minded
and maybe going for some kind of
phoenix package or some other kind of
open source package then staying on
linux does make sense okay
next the elephant in the room uh so when
people are migrating from windows linux
the first question they inevitably have
is that
will i get ms office will i get get ms
word microsoft word in linux
well you can have through the use of
wine or
such other intermediate softwares but uh
and that would not be an ideal solution
okay there are alternatives to it and
please note that the dot dot x
uh
extension this those files with the dot
dot x uh
uh
extension
that is not something which can be
created only using microsoft word okay
that can very well be created with using
other softwares for example you have the
widely used libra office which is an
excellent piece of software uh you can
actually have proper mathematical
equations including a latex input
within uh libreoffice
writer okay i've tried it out myself
it's it's an extension it it can it's a
breeze to install it you can install it
within two minutes uh
the the latex extension okay so you
don't have to get hung up on ms word and
uh
often times the the argument that is put
forward against libreoffice is that a
document which is created in ms word
maybe there's a lot of indentation and
formatting it doesn't get reflected
properly in libreoffice i agree okay so
some of those doc
formatting
and styles and
various other things which you create in
ms word doesn't get reflected properly
in libre office but if you're
collaborating with someone i have
noticed that students nowadays what they
do is they don't go for either ms office
or libreoffice they just go for
something like google docs okay because
it makes collaboration that much easy so
if you're collaborating with someone go
for google docs okay so
and if you're using it if you're using
or if you're trying to create a document
on your own
just the output matters like you want to
print out a report or you want to just
make a pdf out of it then just use
libreoffice what's stopping you
okay and finally graphics uh well uh
i won't lie to you
now adobe photoshop uh and
adobe illustrator they are really really
good okay like if you are a professional
graphics artist those are the things
that you that you probably need to use
like
in industry but
let's go back to the original motivation
of this discussion okay i'm talking i'm
making this video especially for
students for mechanical engineering
aerospace
students maybe for some circular branch
students also who are on the fence about
using linux for you guys
i can
i can envisage no situation where you
would do something so very
uh like terribly fantastic that you'd
actually need the professional versions
of these
adobe's packages now had to be
illustrated or had to be photoshopped
okay so whatever you you need to do
really okay whatever you really need to
do using photoshop you can very well do
it using [ __ ]
the free and open source uh
graphics package or for scalable vector
graphics instead of adobe illustrated
you can use inkscape okay and inkscape
has actually improves tremendously i
have been used using inkscape for like
more than 12 years now and in almost all
my papers
not almost all in all my papers
like the actual journal papers which is
uh
from my research work
every schematic figure has been created
using inkscape okay so these are like
professional publication level uh
figures
nothing to fancy i don't need that
whatever i need i can create using
inkscape okay so this is the situation
i've laid bare in front of you all the
facts the truth as it is
uh
you decide for yourself what you want to
do like if i have to summarize
everything
unless you actually want to become a
professional
uh like a solidworks guy
okay there is no reason for you to shy
away from linux this is my personal
feeling and now you decide okay all the
best